we already know a little bit about
square roots for example if i were to
tell you that 7 squared is equal to 49
that's equivalent to saying that 7 is
equal to the square root of 49. the
square root essentially unwinds taking
the square of something in fact we could
write it like this we could write the
square root of 49 so this is whatever
number times itself is equal to 49
if i multiply that number times itself
if i square it well i'm going to get 49
and that's going to be true for any
number not just not just 49 if i write
this if i write the square root of x
and if i were to square it that's going
to be equal to x and that's going to be
true for any x for which we can evaluate
the square root evaluate the principal
root now typically and as you advance in
math you're going to see that this will
change but typically you say okay if i'm
going to take the square root of
something x has to be non-negative
x has to be
non-non-negative this is going to be
this is going to change once we start
thinking about thinking about imaginary
and complex numbers but typically for
the principle square root we assume that
whatever is under the radical whatever
is under here is going to be
non-negative because it's hard to square
a number at least the numbers that we
know about it's hard to square them and
get a negative number so for this thing
to be defined for it to make sense it's
typical to say that okay we need to put
a non-negative number in here
but anyway the focus of this video is
not on the square root it's really just
to review things so we can start
thinking about the cube root
and as you can imagine this where does
this where does the whole notion of
taking a square of something or square
root come from well it comes from the
notion of finding the area of a square
if i have a square like this
and if this side is 7 well if it's a
square all the sides are going to be 7
and if i wanted to find the area of this
it would be 7 times 7 or 7 squared that
would be the area of this
now or if i were to say well what is
if i have a square if i have and that
doesn't look like a perfect square but
you get the idea all the sides are the
same length if i have a square with area
x
if the area here is x what are the
lengths of the sides going to be
well it's going to be square root of x
all on the sides are going to be square
root of x so it's going to be square
root of x by square root of x and this
side is going to be square root of x as
well and that's going to be square root
of x as well so that's where the term
square root comes from where the square
comes from now what do you think cube
root
well same idea if i have a cube if i
have a cube let me my best attempt at
drawing a cube really fast
if i have a cube
and a cube all of its dimensions have
the same length so this is a 2 by 2 by 2
cube what's the volume over here
well the volume is going to be 2 times 2
times 2 which is 2 to the 3rd power or 2
cubed
this is 2 cubed that's why they use the
word cubed because this would be the
volume of a cube where each of its sides
have length 2 and this of course is
going to be equal to 8.
but what if we went the other way around
what if we started with the cube
or what if we started with this volume
what if we if we started with a cube's
volume and let's say the volume
here is eight
cubic units
so volume
is equal to eight and we wanted to find
the lengths of the sides so we wanted to
figure out what x
we wanted to figure out what x is
because that's x that's x and that's s
it's a it's a cube so all its dimensions
have the same length
well there's two ways that we could
express this we could say that x times x
times x or x to the third power is equal
to eight
or
we could use the cube root symbol which
is a radical with a little three in the
right place or
or we could write that x is equal to
it's going to look very similar to the
square root
this would be the square root of 8 but
to make it clear that we're talking
about the cube root of 8 we would write
a little 3 over there
in theory for square root you could put
a little 2 over here but that'd be
redundant if there's no number here
people just assume that it's the square
root but if you're figuring out the cube
root or sometimes people say the third
root then well then you have to say well
you have to put this little three right
over here in the this little notch in
the radical symbol right over here and
so this is saying x is going to be some
number that if i cube it i get eight so
with that other way let's let's do some
examples
let's say that i have
let's say that i want to calculate
the cube root
the cube root of 27 what's that going to
be
well if i say that this is going to be
equal to x this is equivalent to saying
that x to the third or that 27 is equal
to x to the third power
so what is x going to be
well
x times x times x is equal to 27 well
the number i can think of
is three so we would say that x let me
scroll down a little bit x is equal to
three
now let me ask you a question
can we write
can we write something like
can we pick a new color the cube root of
let me write negative 64. i already
talked about that if we're talking the
square root it's fairly typical that hey
you put a negative number in there at
least until we learn about imaginary
numbers we don't know what to do with it
but can we do something with this
well if i multiply if i cube something
can i get a negative number
sure if i take so if i say this is equal
to x
this is the same thing as saying that
negative 64 is equal to x to the third
power well what could x be
well what happens if you take negative 4
times negative 4
times negative 4.
negative 4 times negative 4 is positive
16 but then times negative 4 is negative
64 is equal to negative 64.
so what could x be here well x could be
equal to negative 4. x could be equal to
negative 4.
so based on the math that we know so far
you actually can take the cube root of a
negative number
and just so you know you don't have to
stop there you could take a fourth root
in this case you would have a four here
a fifth root a sixth root a seventh root
of numbers and we'll talk about that in
well later in your mathematical career
but most of what you see is actually
going to be square root and every now
and then you're going to see a cube root
now you might be saying well hey look
you know you just knew that 3 to the
third power is 27 you took the cube root
you get x is there any simple way to do
this and like you know if i give you an
arbitrary number if i were to just say
i don't know if i were to say cube root
of
cube root of
and the simple answer is well
you know the easiest way to actually
figure this out is actually just to do a
factorization in particular prime
factorization of this thing right over
here and then you would figure it out so
you would say okay well 125 is 5 times
25 which is 5 times 5 all right so this
is the same thing as the cube root
of 5 to the third power which of course
is going to be equal to which is going
to be equal to 5. if you have a much
larger number here yes it there's no
there's no very simple way to compute
what a cube root or a fourth root or a
fifth root might be and even square root
can get
quite difficult it doesn't there's no
very simple way to just calculate it the
way that you might multiply things or
divide it